foreign
s at Budapest Airport angry their team
lost the Europa League final and now
convinced they had found the person to
blame
Anthony Taylor the English referee
traveling home with his family the focus
of all this abuse the group just about
safely ushered into a side room at the
airport moments later a chair is hurled
in their Direction
but was this man the Catalyst Jose
Mourinho the Roma manager was one of 14
people booked during an ill-tempered
match
he then waited in the car park to
confront the referee
[Music]
swearing at him in multiple languages
and calling Taylor a disgrace
Mourinho like both the clubs involved in
this game has now been charged by UEFA
with breaking rules but it was at the
airport where anger turned into violence
he's got his wife out there to witness
one of the greatest days of his life
he's done the game had a real real tough
match he's at the airport coming back
and that's not the memories you want
it's terrible that's the only word I can
use
sympathy too from other football
managers I'm so sorry for for the images
I saw for Anthony Taylor I'm so sorry
so hopefully not done happen again so
there's only I can say
Anthony Taylor used to be a prison
officer he's a robust character but he
didn't expect or deserve this nor did
the family who had to cow with him on an
ugly day for football Adam Parsons Sky
News